- Hi, I'm Dave from Khan
Academy, and I want to show you
how you can preview and make assignments
from right within the Teacher Dashboard.
So let's take a look at
how the Content tab works.
From your Teacher homepage,
click into a class,
and you'll see the Content tab.
Scroll down, and you'll see
all the Khan Academy units
for the subject you've
assigned to that class.
Skim through the units and select any one
to view different sections of that unit
and then individual resources,
like videos, articles, and exercises,
quizzes and unit tests.
For example, this unit begins
with a two-minute video,
an article, and then a
seven-question problem set.
By clicking Preview next to a resource,
you can watch the video, read the article,
or view the full item bank for an exercise
before assigning it to your class.
Looking for something
in a different subject
or a different grade level?
You can select additional subjects
and then quickly switch
from one to another
to create the perfect
assignments for your students.
And then it's decision time.
Select a single assignment or multiple.
You can now assign several
resources at the same time.
So select your assignment
and then click Assign.
Like usual, choose the
classes, students, and due date
for your assignments.
Even though this if
for Period 1 right now,
I could make these assignment
to all of my classes at once,
or I could assign them
to specific students
within my class.
Then I either assign them
to students immediately,
or I save the assignments to post later.
Saved assignments will
show up under Assignments
by clicking the Saved tab.
We hope the Content
tab will make it easier
for you to make the assignments
that your students need.
Check out the content tab today.